obviously is quite a problem how do you
make d2o
because normally the deuterium in the
water is diluted by a factor of seven
thousand which for chemists is really
pretty dilute the best way of making d2o
is by process called electrolysis where
you pass a current through the water to
make hydrogen the process was first
carried out on the large scale in Norway
just before the Second World War in
Norway which is a very mountainous
country they have a lot of cheap
electricity from hydro power rivers
going over waterfalls so they have
electricity and it makes economic sense
to generate hydrogen to make them for
making ammonia and fertilizers by
electrolyzing water and if you
electrolyze water you find that the h2o
reacts a little bit faster than the d2o
so if you go on electrolyzing more and
more of water and keeping what's left
and then doing several stages of
electrolysis you can gradually
concentrate more and more of the d2o
till eventually is nearly pure this
process was carried out in a fairly
remote power station in central Norway
in an region called Telemark now one of
the main uses of d2o
in the early stages of nuclear science
was for making nuclear reactors nuclear
parents and during the Second World War
the British and the Americans were
terrified that Germany who occupied
Norway in those at that time might get
hold of the d2o
and start nuclear research and in one of
the best raids of the whole Second World
War six Norwegians attacked the power
station destroyed the heavy water
writers and retreat it and the reason it
was so successful is that nobody was
injured and nobody was killed so they
got into the place blew it up and
escaped without anybody being injured
and in fact the German general that
investigated thought it was one of them
as magnificent military feats he'd ever
seen there's another story that before
the Germans invaded Norway that the
supply of heavy water two cans a few
gallons was smuggled out to the UK and
it was so valuable it is said that it
was put under King George the sixth bed
overnight so it should be safe before it
was then transported to America is that
true well this is the the legend and the
story is that when it was flown to
America in an unheated plane the water
froze so when the people took it off it
sounded as if the cans were empty and
they got really worried but then it
warmed up and melted d2o has a number of
applications but it's real use is in a
technical nuclear magnetic resonance
we've shown it on our video about T how
you can use it to analyze molecules and
nuclear magnetic resonance is very
sensitive to hydrogen atoms so if you
want to study some sort of molecules
dissolved in water if you use ordinary
water the hydrogen atoms in the water
have such a strong signal that you can't
study the dissolved molecules at all so
instead you use d 2o which do not
respond to the same frequencies as the
hydrogen and so you get a nice spectrum
I think people watching will have two
questions
what does heavy water taste like and
what will happen to me if I drink it
well I've never tasted d2o I suspect
that it will taste really quite similar
to h2o though it's difficult to predict
because
sometimes things taste quite different
but water doesn't really taste anyway
you usually taste what's dissolved in
the water salts or whatever there is a
strong body of opinion that d2o
is quite poisonous and the reason why
it's poisonous is because in your body
you have all sorts of molecules that
have hydrogen bonded particularly to
oxygen and the DS bonds break as part of
the various chemical processes in your
body
deuterium oxygen bonds are slightly
stronger than hydrogen oxygen bonds and
therefore if you start changing your
body for the the chemicals in your body
from hydrogen to deuterium these bones
will break more slowly and so various
processes in your body are likely to
slow right down if they slow down they
may completely stop well I was always
told that you could kill someone by
making a cup of tea with d2o because
while it does is there's a difference
between the way that hydrogen reacts and
deuterium reacts in the body so it can
replace hydrogen in the body and
obviously it's everywhere it's in all
the water and it's in all the enzymes
that are in your body but I have since
read that apparently need to replace
about 50% of the water in your body to
actually kill you with DTO which is kind
of impractical so would-be murderers
don't try that one - at work there is a
rumor which I've never been able to
verify that the Argonne lab in the
United States just outside Chicago at
one time had a deuterated dog which had
been brought up and fed on d2o
but I think this is probably just an
urban myth and it never happened there's
also a suggestion that if you dilute
your whiskey with d 2o rather than h2o
that you might not get so dizzy when you
drink too much but you might be dead so
it's not something that one should try
in any way it's far too expensive